[Music]
covering the weatherbeat here in whisty
Palm Beach actually we're here to
interview the former president and now
the Republican front runner Donald Trump
while the rest of us has spent the last
two and a half years arguing about
systemic racism and trans rights and
other ephemera other imaginary things
America's position globally has eroded
so fast it defies belief but Donald
Trump has noticed things have really
changed since he left office and that's
the topic of this next part of the
conversation here it is
you said at the time when you were
president that going to war with Russia
either hot war or cold war would drive
Russia into an alliance with China that
would displace us as the most powerful
Nation I did
but we have a bigger problem the bigger
problem is the Weaponry the Weaponry
today is so powerful this isn't like
second world war where we have army
tanks running around shooting each other
this is
weapons the likes of which the world has
never seen before they have them and we
have them
and China has them less but within five
years China will have equal to us China
I'm talking about nuclear
China has
the beginnings of a very big very
powerful nuclear they're short five
years they had started much later
Russia and us are comparable massive
power massive
and that's one of the things more than
people understanding more than people
understand yeah yeah more were you
surprised and the power if you look at
Hiroshima Hiroshima some people call it
if you look at Nagasaki you look at
those two events took place many many
years ago
and multiply that power times 500.
that's what you're talking about where
it actually melted the granite you know
Granite is unmeltable by blow torches
yes but the granted if you look at
Granite areas it's like water
that got you know hardened like an ice
skating rink
it melted the granite
if you look at that and multiply times
that's what you're talking about
when I listened to people talking about
global warming that the ocean will rise
in the next 300 years by 1 8 of an inch
and they talk about this is a big
problem is nuclear warming when nobody
even talks about it the environmental is
talking about all this
nonsense in many cases look I'm a
environmentalist also I guess in my own
way because I've done a good job with
the environment but
nobody talks about nuclear the problem
the problem we have the biggest problem
we have in the whole world
it's not global warming it's nuclear
warming and all it takes is one mad man
and you're going to have a problem the
likes of which the world has never seen
and it's only a matter of seconds you
don't have to wait two to three hundred
years for it to happen
so what you're saying is demonstrably
true
why is this not something our leaders
talk about or the Press talks about
because I don't think they're smart I
don't think they get it Putin got it I
would talk to him about it all the time
I never mentioned the word nuclear you
never heard me mention the word
you know my uncle was a professor a
great professor at MIT for a long time
for I think he has the longest Dr John
Trump
and he would talk about a lot of
different things and it was very
interesting to me for years I talked to
him passed away as a great great
gentleman
I think it's the longest tenured
professor in the history of MIT but if
he wasn't he was very close because if
for almost 40 years
and we talk about things and he said you
know someday
they'll have a suitcase
and in that suitcase
it'll be nuclear
and you'll blow up New York City
out of a suitcase and I said no Uncle
John that can't possibly he's right
the power is so incredible you can fire
up a submarine and run it for years
on essentially a tablet
running for years
so when we talk about war and when I
watch all of the people talking about
Ukraine and how's Ukraine doing blah
blah blah
gracious sitting back first of all
Ukraine's being obliterated yes okay
let's not even talk nuclear but let's
say it wasn't let's say they were doing
better than anticipated
if he decided to use a second form of
destruction which is nuclear
that's the end of that you understand
and I know where you are in Ukraine so I
mean you understand it better than most
most people done it most people don't
even talk about it they don't talk about
the fact that he has equal to the United
States and nuclear
capability and destruction
and so I watch all of this happening and
it's so sad but can I assess the the
Biden people know the power of nuclear
weapons they now control our Arsenal
they don't seem worried about this uh
that's because they don't understand
life they don't understand whatever it
is that you have to understand you know
it's very interesting at the very
beginning Biden was very afraid of
nuclear because I watched him and he's
oh they have nuclear weapons oh they
which was exactly the wrong signal to
send you don't do that
but if you go back and check your files
you'll see Biden early on
saying oh well we can't do this they
have nuclear weapons but you don't want
to you know you don't want to act that
way yeah but he was very afraid of
nuclear I said you know you got to be a
little bit cooler than that
but what happened is now that nobody
talks about it but every day Putin
mentions it and every day other people
mention it and now all of a sudden if
you look other countries are talking
about getting it this was something you
don't mention I call it the n-word
you have two n-words you don't mention
either one of them
the nuclear word you don't mention
because the power's so destructive I met
with professors at MIT
and
I Was preparing for a debate I wouldn't
say it was a long preparation but I did
want to talk about nuclear because I
consider it to be the single greatest
threat the world has far greater than
global warming it's like not even a
contest
and I had these people come down
they were very smart
very expert and I said so
when we start talking about nuclear in a
debate how would you handle it
and they
looked at me one in particular and said
sir
you can't talk about it
you cannot talk about it
I said what does that mean he said
it is so massive it is so destructive
that you cannot talk about it I
understood exactly what he meant
and uh
we stayed away from it for the most part
but now Putin's mentioning it all the
time
we don't mention but Putin's always
mentioning it you've heard him say it we
are a nuclear power he said not so long
ago I said that's the first time I've
heard a major country you know you do
hear it talked about and I did a good
job I did a great job with North Korea
Kim Jong-un you went with me on a trip
you insulted him which didn't make my
didn't make my life too easy but that's
okay but you were there one of the few
and it was an amazing it had to be one
of the most incredible experiences for
you for sure but it was amazing uh we
had thousands of reporters
they weren't treated particularly nicely
either by the way but I got along great
with him and because of that started
rough remember with you know Rocket Man
Little Rocket Man and he said I have a
button on my desk a red button I said I
have a red button on my desk too mine's
bigger and mine works yours doesn't and
this went on for a couple of months and
then all of a sudden
The Log Jam was broken and he wanted to
meet and we did meet and we get along
great to this day we get along great
he won't talk to Biden he won't even
talk to these people he won't even talk
to him he has no respect for him he's a
man he'd like avv respects respects you
he wouldn't talk to Obama Obama tried to
get meetings with him he wouldn't meet
with him he met with me I met with him
twice
I would have had a deal worked out with
him he's got tremendous nuclear
capability
it's the single biggest problem maybe
this shows more important than even I
thought it might be because somebody's
got to understand what has to happen and
they have to de-escalate so how would
you do that now well now so you have a
problem you got this crazy world that's
blowing up in the United States has
absolutely no say and macron who's a
friend of mine is over with China
kissing his ass
okay in China I said France is now going
to China you take a look at
Saudi Arabia look at what happened
they're great people
they wanted to help us
he goes over gets a fist pump you know
what a fist pump means don't shake my
hand because your hand's dirty that's
what a fist bump is they got it and they
were so insulted
do you understand that yes oh I don't
want to shake your hand let's go fist
pump
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight